[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros hoy en 5
minutos con nos acompaña el doctor james
holtz médico especializado en salud
mundial y también catedrático de la
universidad de ciencias aplicadas de
falta en alemania doctor buen día
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 algunos científicos
consultados por la revista médica the
lancet están definiendo el coi 19 como
una cin demia le pregunto qué significa
esto
en el fondo es el término escriba algo
que es o por menos debería ser la
esencia de la de salud pública y mundial
a diferencia de la información
predominante o prácticamente uniforme
sobre 'el hobbit' 19 de coronavirus no
es un fenómeno aislado sino se sobrepone
a los problemas preexistentes en el
mundo real
hay que saber que incluso con el cob y
1919 siguen siendo las enfermedades no
transmisibles o crónicas las que
representan la mayor parte de la carga
de movilidad y causa de muerte todo eso
se da por supuesto en el contexto social
y ambiental que se caracteriza por una
profunda iniquidad socioeconómica tanto
a nivel global nacional como a nivel
global
ahora le pregunto de qué manera el mundo
se estaba enfrentando a esta crisis
sanitaria para pensar en catalogarla
como una endemia bueno hay que reconocer
que hasta ahora el mundo no está
abordando la pandemia de la manera
adecuada y se sigue poniendo énfasis
principal en los aspectos biomédicos
sobre todo de desarrollo de fármacos y
facu y vacunas pero no se tocan los
llamados determinantes de salud ni los
factores que causan pandemias como la
actual ni el impacto indica que en
equitativo de las medidas que se toman
para frenarla lo que se requiere más que
una vacuna contra kobe 19 es una vacuna
en el fondo una vacuna contra la pobreza
y contra la iniquidad se podría entonces
pensar que eeuu por ejemplo es el país
cualquier que es el país con el mayor
número de contagios en el mundo sea el
ejemplo de lo que es una sin demia
porque ahí convergen un sinnúmero de
enfermedades
bueno aun cuando percibimos de cubrir 10
y luego como las ingenia sigue siendo
una pandemia lo que significa que afecta
a todos los países del mundo de la forma
de forma más o menos igual lo que
distingue de eeuu de otros países de
alto ingreso como canadá australia y
europa no es tanto la carga de
enfermedad que es más o menos parecido
parecida sino
el mayor grado de inequidad social y
socioeconómica hay un creciente número
de pruebas científicas que muestran
claramente que tanto el riesgo de
enfermarse como de sufrir síntomas
severos o morir es mucho mayor en los
grupos socioeconómicos más bajos en el
caso de kobe 19 eso
se ve agravado por el mayor impacto en
las medidas que se toman frente a la
pandemia en las capas sociales
inferiores ahora autor como se puede
llamar al caso de la india porque ya la
situación es de mucha desigualdad y es
visible además a la vista toda la
desigualdad que se vive en india
bueno lo que pasa que los datos hasta
ahora son bastante prematuros en
completos pero todo hace suponer que el
19 se comporta de la misma forma como
todas las países pero todos los países
confían más a las capas sociales e
incluso en el caso de la india las
castas de inferiores que llevan la carga
de morbilidad más alta de por sí
mientras que las capas sociales más
altas viven en casas más espaciosas más
amplias y pueden trabajar en casa por
ejemplo las condiciones de vida de
muchos indios hacen imposible aplicar
las medidas de distanciamiento físico sí
y además las décimas de nutrición reduce
la defensa del cuerpo y los hacen más
susceptibles de infectarse y sufrir
consecuencias más severas doctor muy
rápidamente es más grave esto que la
pandemia
en el debate sobre el tema
el fondo del debate sobre salud pública
por una parte del comité sino
concientizar la unidad de la de tu grado
de interrelación del mundo globalizado
de hoy y de la relevancia mundial
foros animarte el espeso y mezquino
enfoque a los aspectos biomédicos no ha
desplazado los grandes desafíos que
enfrentamos and global doctor gracias
por estar con nosotros que tenga usted
un feliz día hasta aquí y cinco minutos
con continuo con nosotros
[Música]